the cleveland browns go back to kansas
city to start the season joe woods the
defensive coordinator recently spoke
with reporters uh and and he talked
about the fact that you know the offense
is great but on the defensive side of
the ball they really did end up playing
a pair of first round picks in greg
newsome and jeremiah owosu koromoa
here's woods talking about that
to me it felt like we got
uh two first rounders for sure and then
with greg
both you know greg and jlk
those guys are very smart players
they're very uh competitive players they
just bring a different element to the
team i mean they come out there and they
just go hard all the time
they're trying to learn as much football
as they can
the versatility we're playing with
multiple positions to see what they're
capable of doing so it's been good
having both of those guys involved
yeah and you consider the fact they have
the number one overall pick from 2017
and miles garrett they got the number
one overall pick from 20
13 or 14
14 in jadav and clowney they got some
some guys with significant pedigree on
that side of the football and we talked
about this not long ago the browns on
both sides of the ball potentially elite
in in a league where
there aren't a lot of teams that have
true balance at a high level they've got
a high level on both sides of the ball
and now you add in a first rounder in
greg newsom and a guy who
would have been could have been should
have been a first rounder and jeremiah
so jeremiah was coramoa a guy the browns
actually thought about taking instead of
newsom they get both of them
if if it
i know yeah i mean maybe we should have
had the browns maybe we should have the
browns in the no excuses draft the other
day because there really are no excuses
remember i was gonna pick them right but
you had picked an organization right
before it i kind of just chickened out
but yeah i mean look at this guy first
off heat seeking missile like when i say
give zero f's about his body or anything
like that i mean that's where
it's gonna change their football team
around the thing they needed was speed
at the second level and we've talked
about this a lot mike you know it that
seattle scheme to make it work you need
athletic fast linebackers they didn't
have that this guy
is as fast as
greg newsom the corner or you know
safeties in football you know really
it's amazing that you know you're saying
it right the roster is it's it's almost
perfect there is no excuses i mean i
know it's not perfect but it's damn good
there's no really weak area on the
football team and i mean for my money
you could switch around i think obusu
coramoa should have gone to pick 26 and
and greg newsome had picked 52 either
way newsome's a incredible fit for their
their scheme you know he's long rangy
richard sherman type of body and really
playing style to me that fits that
seattle scheme as well he's not going to
be to me like the greatest man-to-man
island lockdown corner but he's got
incredible ball skills he's got length
and he's got a he knows how to play the
game he's going to know how to play zone
and read coverages in the combination so
how could joe woods not be excited about
his defense and what they did i added to
jedevian clowney and some of the other
guys they've gotten like wow john you
know john johnson from the rams i mean
it's really phenomenal the roster right
now
not a lot of questions around this team
during the break between offseason
workouts and the start of training camp
baker mayfield's agent recently said
that oh yeah there's a belief that
mayfield will have his contract at some
point this summer i still think that
mayfield allen waiting for lamar jackson
because the one thing you don't want to
do is provide the template for jackson
that then gets used by jackson his
mother and whoever else is advising the
process as the floor
for jackson's deal make jackson do his
and then you do yours i think that's the
way it's going to fall i think it's
going to be jackson mayfield allen let
me ask you this
with no guarantee that allen's going to
get his
this summer although i think he should
yeah i think he should too let me ask
you this if you're them right and i
think we hit on this when we brought
this up a little while ago
but are you scared if you're mayfield
and allen
because of maybe lack of representation
for lamar jackson that if they go first
they might take a contract that's a
little low and now you
you know have less to stand on would you
worry about that aspect if you're in
there those two you know camp
i don't want yeah if if jackson goes
first and his deal is bad
it's an easy response by mayfield or
alan's agent it's an aberration yeah he
didn't have an agent right ignore that
yeah we've got we'll we'll do our deal
we'll use the dak prescott deal as our
template he had an agent we're not going
to use the the deal that lamar jackson
did because he didn't have an agent but
i don't think you want to go before him
i don't think you want to go i mean you
want to go after him you don't want to
go before him because i think it's
easier to get the best possible deal and
not look bad in comparison to the guy
who didn't have an agent if you go first
and he goes after that sets the stage
for it possibly being ugly so i watch
for jackson's deal to be done i would
say maybe even before the fourth of july
it could be done by then who knows but i
think mayfield will be after that and if
not but all three guys are under
contract for two more years and uh you
know maybe one of these teams is just
going to decide to let it ride get one
more year of proof before you make that
long-term financial commitment
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports